just wrote about it
others were
others wrote about it and
the story went out all over the country
all over the world that a couple of
yemenis on the terror watch list had
been apprehended at the border
the next day story's gone
and even the reuters report and all the
other reports
they linked to customs and border
patrol's press release but she went to
customs and border patrol press release
and it said access denied
the news was gone
and it has never returned and it's never
been explained
it's clear though what's going on that
the
uh biden administration aided by a
compliant sycophantic media
is determined to ensure as much
complacency and ignorance
as they possibly can and so they erase
the
news
and most people don't know what happened
and now you can't find out anything that
anything that will tell you that it did
happen except crackpot wingnut sites
like jihadwatch and who listens to them
so
this is just one incident of many
because in the first place we know that
the binding administration lies
that they lie like they breathe they lie
as a matter of course and that if they
tell you that two
you meant two people on the terror watch
list were caught
probably others were as well
and then of course they're the others
who weren't caught we know that the
border patrol has had for years a
category called otms other than mexicans
of people who are crossing the border
who are not mexican nationals often
posing as mexican nationals and they
come in from afghanistan from iraq from
somalia from nigeria from other jihad
terror hot spots
and they come into the united states for
there was a hezbollah operative active
in michigan a few years ago and he was
active in the united states for quite a
few years before he was apprehended
turned out when he was arrested that he
had crossed over illegally from mexico
this is something that jihadis had been
exploiting for years and now biden's
people have made it easier than ever
so that's the border
then
there's all these
they're all these afghan refugees
now the afghan refugees
this is an incredible snafu
you probably have heard in the first
place that we owe it to these people
right we owe them
a favor we owe them safety we owe them a
new life in a new land because they
stuck their neck out next out in
afghanistan for us
they were interpreters for the us
military they aided the military in
other ways and so we got to take care of
them
it's just honorable
now of course the problem here
is that here again the biden
administration
which is utterly mendacious and
completely and dishonest and never
releases
the information that makes it look bad
to its fullest extent
has acknowledged
that most of these afghans that we're
bringing into the united states 95
afghans we're bringing into the united
states
thousands of the morory here
they're not the interpreters
they're not actually the people we owe
the favors at all
and so the whole thing has been sold to
the american people on false pretenses
it's a bill of goods the whole thing
there are two kinds of people that we've
been told make up the group of afghans
who are refugees in the united states or
soon will be
one is the uh special immigrant visa
holders and the other of the
interpreters
and the biden administration has already
acknowledged the special immigrant visa
holders are the special immigrant visas
are given to people like the
interpreters to fast track their way
into the united states
you know uh returning returning the
favor they did for us
these are not the people we're bringing
in
so who are the people we're bringing in
nobody knows
nobody has any idea who these people are
and remember they're not coming from
france
they're not coming from
england
they're coming from afghanistan
afghanistan is a jihadi hot spot anyway
you slice it there are people there who
don't like the taliban why because they
favor isis
there are people there who are not
affiliated with the taliban because
they're affiliated with al qaeda
are there a lot of people in afghanistan
who are ozzie nelson in kandahar who are
going to come over to the united states
and be fine upstanding citizens yes i'm
sure there are a few
but
most of the people in afghanistan
not just some but most
believe that waging jihad against
unbelievers
is a
righteous and honorable thing that will
get them rewards from allah and not only
do they think that
but
they believe in sharia and islamic law
sharia
mandates discrimination against women
discrimination against non-muslims
vicious anti-semitism all kinds of
things
that are going to make for societal
friction
when you have large amounts and we're
bringing over 95 that's the number
they've admitted so it's probably more
than 95 000 people we're bringing into
the united states
and they have this
vastly different point of view
and
they generally believe that it is
meritorious to wage jihad against
unbelievers they're coming into this
landfill of unbelievers
what might some of them do
and then there's the hydra
islamic law
teaches that you will be
at the end of your life
go before the awesome judgment of allah
and he has these big scales this is
chapter 21 verse 47 of the quran you can
look it up
and the big scales your good deeds go in
one and your bad deeds go in the other
and if your good deeds outweigh your bad
deeds then you go to paradise if your
bad deeds outweigh your good deeds you
go to hell
now imagine if you believed that
it would i speaking strictly for myself
it would drive me crazy
and i would probably become a jihadi why
because jihad is the way out of the
craziness that this idea gives you now
at first glance it seems
completely innocuous okay so your good
deeds and your bad deeds are in the
scale so try to be good big deal
but
think about it some more
how much do your good deeds weigh
how much do your bad deeds weigh
how many good deeds have you committed
how many bad deeds have you committed
nobody knows the answers to those
questions
and so
if you are a believing muslim
and you're afraid of hell and hell is
very luridly and deep and just blurredly
described and described in tremendous
detail in the quran
then you're going to go nuts thinking
okay
what if my bad deeds outweigh my good
deeds what am i gonna do
how am i gonna avoid going to hell
where i'm gonna get my skin roasted off
and then allah will issue me a new skin
so i can be tortured some more and where
he'll make me drink molten lead those
things are in the quran and more
how can i avoid this
well
the quran guarantees paradise to those
who kill and are killed for a lot this
is chapter 9 verse 11.
if you
wan or want to be sure that you're going
to paradise then
strap on a suicide bomb and blow
yourself up in the crowd of infidels and
you have killed and you have killed and
been killed for a lot you're going
straight to paradise do not pass go do
not collect 200
you're all set
but maybe you don't want to do that
obviously that's very difficult
and most human beings love life and they
don't want to
blow themselves up in a crowd of
infidels no matter what the inducements
may be to do that
most muslims don't want to do that
it goes against everything that is part
of human nature
so the quran also gives you another
thing you can do
chapter 4 verse 100
says
that if you
emigrate in the way of allah
then you will get great reward from
allah
emigrate you leave your country you go
to another country to bring islam to it
you're not just going to the other
country to
get a good job or to be safe out of a
war zone you have to bring islam to the
new country
if you do that you're going to get
rewards from allah that's probably going
to tip the scales in your favor
and so it's a very appealing idea to a
pious knowledgeable muslim
to emigrate
in the way of allah as a matter of fact
that's the beginning of islam not when
muhammad became a prophet not when
muhammad was born or died but islam
becomes islam according to the islamic
calendar year one of the islamic
calendar is when muhammad emigrated
left mecca from medina and became
a military and political leader as well
as a spiritual one
so
you have all these people coming are
some of them thinking that they're
emigrating in the cause of allah
i don't think there's any doubt about
that there's no way that could not be so
that at least some of them think they're
going to bring islam here which means
bring life-beating here bring
anti-semitism here bring jihad against
infidels here all these things are part
of islam
and some of them are going to be
thinking that
main thing is though we have no idea who
these people are as i said before
and i'll be very clear about this
just the other day
the biden administration
had to admit which is how it usually
happens had to admit under pressure
that there are 12 000 afghan refugees in
the united states now they have already
gotten here
and they are already being resettled in
american cities
and they don't have any id whatsoever
so they tell us
on the news you know jake tapper and
brian stelter and those guys will tell
us these people are all being very
carefully vetted
but the real story came out
when representative daryl isa from
california went to
cutter
to a camp near doha
where these afghans are being processed
and then brought to the united states
and he went with a congressional
delegation
a bunch of congressmen
they wouldn't let them in
they stopped them at alludate air base
in doha they wouldn't let them in
to the camp where the afghans are why
not
who knows
but
in the course of their discussions with
the military officials they were talking
to at aludaid
they were told that these guys are
coming into the united states with no
identification whatsoever they do not
have any idea who they are
so how could they possibly have vetted
them
they could not have possibly vetted them
there is no way you can vet somebody
when you don't know who he is
so they're gonna check to see if these
guys are jihadis meanwhile these people
are in the american military which
doesn't even admit there is a jihad they
don't know what jihadists think they
don't know what jihadis believe i used
to train military men in in military
officers excuse me in how to deal with
understanding
what jihadis believed
and obama stopped that 10 years ago
so
how are they going to know how to vet in
the first place and how and how are they
going to check the backgrounds of these
people and see if they're in the taliban
or in isis or in al qaeda and remember
also
there was a prison at bagram air base in
kabul
the united states air base bagram air
base in afghanistan
and there were thousands not just a
couple there were thousands of isis and
al qaeda prisoners in it and the us
under the biden administration left
bagram air base in the dark of night
without telling even the afghan national
army our supposed allies not telling
them we were leaving just up and left
and when they get up the next morning
and we're gone
the taliban comes in not long after that
and they open the prison doors and all
these people go out the isis and al
qaeda guys and
not long after that you see the long
lines at the kabul airport people trying
to get on the transports to the united
states
who got on the transports but the most
the strongest the most ruthless the best
armed why because you got you got a huge
crush of people how are you gonna fight
through it
unless you're tough
unless maybe you're a jihadi unless
you're a young man of military age who
can overpower the other people in the
line and get to the front
so any number of isis and al qaeda guys
is likely among these people we don't
know who they are and meanwhile
then we have the enemy within
now you might think i'm talking about
the muslim brotherhood or something no
i'm talking about the catholic church
pardon me if you're catholic i'm sorry i
don't mean any offense actually i'm
talking about refugee resettlement the
catholic church got at last report 95
million dollars a year
for refugee resettlement from the united
states government
and so they have 95 million reasons to
press the us government to
bring in more refugees
there has never been any indication that
pope francis or the bishops in the
united states have any idea of what
they're
subjecting the western countries to when
they push for
mass migration
they have a huge financial incentive to
push for mass migration and
at the same time they guilt-trip
catholics and other people into thinking
that they have to be in favor of this
because otherwise they're not welcoming
to the stranger and that's a gospel
virtue
so
all these people are being brought in
catholic charities is resettling them i
saw a story the other day they're giving
them furnished apartments in kansas city
now wouldn't that be i'd like a
furnished apartment in kansas city that
would be nice you know but nobody's
offering these kinds of things to
american citizens uh
there are plenty of people who are in
need in the united states plenty of
people who are
homeless
i'll show you a new one okay
who are poor all kinds of things
it's not just that uh
only these people are in need
there are plenty of people right here
already who are in need but somehow they
have taken precedence so
you get set up you're an afghan refugee
you're a jihadi
you get a nice furnished apartment in
kansas city
you get
settled you
scout out the area
you find a good place
you wait you you you carry out a jihad
massacre
how
possible is that
how likely is that maybe it won't happen
in kansas city it's going to happen
somewhere
in the united states over the next
couple of years we're going to see
criminal activity jihad activity from
refugees from afghanistan who we are
settling with no regard for the safety
and well-being of the american people at
our own expense
courtesy of the united states government
courtesy of the catholic church
and all because of
misplaced ideas about our
responsibilities
and a refusal on an institutional level
on the part of both the us government
and the church to uh and not just the
catholic church i should say of course
also many other churches and other
secular organizations are involved in
refugee resettlement and they all have
the same thing
just happened to be that the kansas city
story i was seeing was connected with
catholic charities but they're all
they're all involved in the same kind of
willful ignorance in terms of refusing
to acknowledge the nature and magnitude
of the jihad threat refusing to
acknowledge the cultural dislocation
that is involved
cultural dislocation let's uh think
about that for a minute
fort mccoy in wisconsin
not long ago there were two afghans who
were arrested two afghan refugees that
barely been over here probably a matter
of days
and they were arrested
one for sexual abuse of a minor and the
other for spousal abuse
now the this story was reported it was
it went out over the national news
but one thing that was not in the
national news stories and never would be
and that is
these guys
were just acting like
they would in afghanistan
they probably didn't realize what they
were doing was illegal in the united
states because it's perfectly fine to do
in afghan culture
and you may say oh spencer you
islamophobe after all these years you
still are such a racist that you would
say such a thing
unfortunately the reality is
that muhammad the prophet of islam
according to islamic tradition
not according to spencer according to
islamic tradition
consummated his marriage with aisha
when she was 9 and he was 54.
and because he is the excellent example
the quran says he's the excellent
example for muslims it's chapter 33
verse 21 of the quran you can check my
word
it says that he is the excellent example
without any qualification that means
anything he did
is good to do
you're all right if you follow muhammad
you imitate muhammad you're you're
you're good
so he's 54 he consummates his marriage
with the nine-year-old child marriage is
rampant in afghanistan in afghanistan
that when we toppled the taliban back in
2003 aid workers went into the refugee
camps and they found that half the girls
of second grade age were already married
and
all of the girls older than second grade
were married what's second grade that's
like that's nine isn't it
nine or ten thereabouts and all the
third grade girls and up were married
all of them
no exceptions
so this guy
comes over to fort mccoy
there's a kid walking by
i think it was a boy actually
and that is another thing that's allowed
in in islam you know the boys like
pearls are there with the virgins of
paradise it's in the koran
bachabazi is something that is the uh
it's the practice of of
uh essentially pedophilia widely
practiced in afghanistan
and the american troops were told
don't bother the afghans our allies when
you see them doing this
it's their culture let it go
so he came over here with
what's the big deal
it's pr he probably did it many times
before in afghanistan
i'm sure he was totally surprised to end
up arrested for doing something he
figured was
like taking a walk in the park
same thing with spousal abuse
the koran says
good women are obedient
as for those from whom you fear
disobedience
mind you
it doesn't say as from those who are
disobedient it says from those from whom
you fear
disobedience
so you know if your wife is
giving you the side eye and you think
she's getting a little out of line and
you think that maybe tomorrow she might
disobey you you can beat her today
it's in the quran chapter 4 verse 34.
so this guy beats his wife and if in in
fort mccoy here again
he had i'm sure he was shocked when he
got arrested
as a matter of fact he probably had
contempt for those arresting him because
it has been a
this is one aspect of islamic polemic
against the west the non-muslim west
that has been little remarked upon
and that is that
muslim polemicists in the islamic world
not in the west but in the islamic world
they tend to say that western men are
soft they don't even beat their wives
they don't dare they're afraid of their
wives
this goes back to the crusades as a
matter of fact you read uh
islamic literature of the time of the
crusades and they say the franks
are
soft men they're easy to beat they're
afraid of their wives even
they don't even beat their wives when
their wives give them lip
so this guy does this and he gets
arrested now we have
95 000 afghans at least that we're
bringing into the united states how many
more of them are going to commit
sexual abuse of a minor spousal or
spousal abuse
it's just asking for all sorts of
societal disruption
and of course nobody talks about this
nobody can say a word about this
because
it's racist bigoted and islamophobic to
do so
and so you know i think about i saw this
story in kansas city that i mentioned
before and there's a photo with the
story
of uh these afghan girls with the hijabs
and the long skirts down to their ankles
uh
playing ball
with some kids you know 12 years old
thereabouts
in kansas city in some gym
and
it's all so great you know i'm sure
those people in kansas city are so
pleased with themselves
and think that they're doing this
wonderful generous righteous thing in
trying to make these people feel at home
and get settled in their new land
and they have no idea what's coming
and they have no idea what the what the
people that they're being so friendly to
are saying about them behind their back
but you know the quran is something that
muslims actually believe in the quran
says of the muslims you are the best of
people the best people on earth are the
muslims that's chapter 3 verse 110
and the unbelievers are the most vile of
created beings that's chapter 98 verse
6.
and so here are these kids playing ball
with these afghans
and everything is great and then they go
home and they say don't don't get too
close don't touch them they're unclean
chapter 9 verse 28 of the quran don't
get too close to them they're vile
they're dirty they're unbelievers
you think that the afghans aren't saying
that
maybe some of them aren't i'm sure
there's some of them are and i'm sure
that there's some of them who think
hooray we're out of this sharia hellhole
maybe we can live a normal life
absolutely
but i'm also sure that there's some of
them who are saying this is what the
quran says
and so we can take these things from
these people because it is their due it
is their duty before allah to take care
of us that's in the quran too
chapter 9 verse 29 fight that against
those who do not believe in do not obey
allah and his messenger and do not
forbid what he is forbidden even if they
are of the people of the book that's us
that's the jews and christians
until they pay the jizya with willing
submission and feel themselves subdued
the jizya is more than just the tax that
you pay if you're a non-muslim in the
islamic state it it signifies
that the job of the non-muslim is to pay
for the upkeep of the muslim
that's our place in the world to take
care of them so they can wage jihad
against us
that's the order of things that allah
has ordained and that's why you see all
the muslim migrants coming over into
europe
and the europeans were sold a bill of
goods and told that they're gonna be the
workforce now because we're getting old
we need young people to take the jobs
that uh we don't have people to take
and they were lied to these people don't
come take jobs they go on welfare
and why do they go on welfare
because
it is our duty to take care of them
and if we don't pay the jizy out right
then we give them welfare payments we
give them furnished apartments in kansas
city and so on
so uh this is just idiocy on a colossal
scale
the the i can't overstate i can't i i
wish i were a paradise you know i i wish
i could be funny and and and make jokes
out of this but the babylon bee couldn't
beat this stuff this is this is just
absolutely staggering stupidity on the
part of
the body administration of course
they're not all they're not only stupid
they're evil as well
in the sense of
they do want to destroy
national distinctions borders
and establish an international order and
this is all part of that
so
there's it's it's uh
there's no denying that this is a very
serious situation
and we can hope that we can turn this
around in 22 and 24. the only possible
way to do it though is if we have uh
actual free elections which is also in
question right now and so uh
well we'll see but uh otherwise we will
just take what comes and
pray hope and don't worry as has been
said and uh keep on doing what's right
remember what uh thomas more said the
times are never so bad
that good people can't be good in them
and so let us strive to do that and
thank you very much
if you have questions comments or death
thought was we can do that now
robert that's terrific uh we've got a
lot of questions in the chat room but i
think because we have a manifold-sized
group
if anyone has a meeting just raise your
hand or use the uh
raised hand symbol down there at the
bottom of your toolbar and we'll have
robert take your questions
uh christina is your hand up
yes christine please go ahead and unmute
yourself
thank you
mr spencer that was a fantastic
presentation i really appreciate how you
intertwine current events with
the
current
and the interpretations there it's
something that we need to be all
disciplined to do i have a couple big
questions
one is have you found any successful or
heard any successful plans
from especially border states to
potentially
defend against those ngos and shut them
down
because like texas
uh
what two billion dollars just in texas
for that catholic ngo the primary one
that's
funneling all these immigrants up so i'd
love to have some solutions or think
tank uh background information on how we
get that done
i haven't heard of any such but i hope
that there is some going on i'm sure
there is
uh i know i saw todd benson mentioned in
the
chat here and certainly the center for
immigration studies and
other groups of that kind are doing
very good work on these issues and some
of it is getting wider traction
the tennessee senators and the governor
of tennessee
recently asked the biden administration
for information about the afghans it was
bringing into tennessee
uh
because pointing out of course that
they're completely unvetted and we have
no idea who they are and so we'll see
how that develops and if
they're able to get any accountability
uh from the administration or if they're
able to push back at all or
rather than just
allow these people to
come into the state and then we're
essentially playing russian roulette
thank you
robert uh maria had a very interesting
question i'd like her to ask ask her a
question or i could read it for you
maria if you want to unmute yourself and
ask or i can read the question
okay can you hear me a little louder
closer to the bike please okay i might
have to be like right you're going to
see my face really close
um can you hear me any better
no it's a little light let me let me
read it
for you because muslims are infiltrating
the law institutions
lawyers i'm going to get the right one
here
skipped over here um
isn't welfare very much a part of the
islamic culture the seven percent
seventh century
is it part of their culture
welfare you mean
a us welfare for immigrants
i'm not sure i understand the question
uh can you explain to me what you have
in mind
uh maria you you say the seven seven
cent caliphate story if i spelled that
right i don't know what the seven cent
is referring to
um yeah that part i got i don't
understand what you mean is welfare part
of islamic culture i mean i i explained
before
about the jizya and how
the idea that non-muslims owe the
muslims upkeep that's very much part of
islamic culture and you look at
the history of jihad uh you could read
my book the history of jihad uh
the uh
history of jihad is full of
accounts of muslims
conquering various countries and then
they
get the non-muslims to pay the jizya
and
as the the the
as the non-muslims are bled dry as they
grow poorer and poorer and their
community is smaller then the conquest
has to continue
so that the revenues don't fall
and actually the decline of various
islamic empires is correlated to
the
lack of conquest the exhaustion of the
subject communities and
thus the loss of the economic base
because it's all based on the tribute
paid by the non-muslims
yes robert you you answered that
correctly i i misspoke she asked as a
question spencer isn't welfare a very
very much a part of the islamic culture
obviously you said yes and explain how
in good detail
i have a question for you if you could
um
the
the judges
across the country we get such a mixed
bag of decisions that are favorable or
unfavorable towards
sharia law or sharia interpretation
do you think that is just sympathetic
uneducated
people or is there
an infusion of
jihadist
islamic supporting
mindsets in the judicial system today
well in the judiciary you've got
judges that you can roughly
classify by the
administrations under which they were
appointed so
they generally follow not always of
course
although the ones who don't follow
the general line of the presidents who
appointed them usually are going to the
left
we never see judges who are appointed by
leftists become conservative and that
you know when that keeps happening and
happens again and again and again you
gotta wonder are these people being
threatened
are they being blackmailed are they
being manipulated in some way
yeah because otherwise it's inexplicable
that you know trump went through so much
trouble to appoint these judges to the
supreme court justices and immediately
they
turn
and start to espouse the positions that
he was supposedly trying to prevent from
being espoused
you gotta wonder but anyway
uh
the thing about leftist judges in
general obama judges
clinton judges of which there's still
quite a few
even bush judges
to some degree
they don't know anything about islam
and they understand that islam is a
religion of peace
and that are some islamophobes hate
mongers in the country like spencer and
bridget gabrielle and so on who think
that islam is some kind of a problem and
depose sharia and sharia as far as they
know they'll know they don't know sharia
from shinola the only thing they know
about sharia is that it's islamic
religious law like
uh jewish law or canon law for
catholics and so they think that these
racist
bigoted hate mongers oppose this
religious law just because they hate
muslims
they don't have any idea about how
sharia is a political authoritarian
supremacist and violent legal code
they don't know any of that and so they
see opposition to sharia or opposition
to
a mosque and they think it's just
bigotry and racism and hatred and so
they rule accordingly
christine christine i thought you had
your hand up do you have another
question if not i have one
yeah unmute yourself please really quick
um
two-part question
do you have
what's your estimate on how many
radical
muslims are crossing over that border
what's your percent of those total that
are coming over
um it's really hard to get to that
number to split it out
yeah i don't even want to give you a a
guess because it would just be a total
guess there's really no way no one knows
right
nobody knows that's the problem
it's not just that i don't know it's
that
border patrol doesn't know
yeah pope biden doesn't know of course
you can say that about everything um
nobody knows
and so
it doesn't even take very many to wreak
havoc remember that
3 000 people were killed on september 11
2001 by 19 hijackers
and so when we think about
the southern border have 19 jihadis
crossed almost certainly
have 38 76 almost certainly
then we got 95 000 afghans
that's a lot of knowledge
that leads me to my second question you
have any insiders or friends that have
provided to you any of the vetting
procedures that they're trying to
i'm sorry right now no insider friend
i used to
we're all in the office
a lot of years have passed here you know
uh
every the in the obama administration
particularly
worked hard to weed out
opposition and politicize the
intelligence agencies and law
enforcement agencies
and i thought i was naive in 2017. i
thought well now this is going to turn
around under trump it didn't instead
those agencies that had been politicized
under obama went to work against the new
administration
and now they're just continuing business
as usual
i don't know anybody inside i don't know
that there is anybody left inside who's
any good i hope so but if there are
they are keeping their head down as they
should and working very stealthily
thank you
uh richard do you have your hand up
could you um mute yourself please
yes
thank you yes rick o'reilly here with my
mom carol anne hello good to see robert
spencer again
likewise
yeah from bakersfield california we have
you've been here a couple times
i was
wondering
your thoughts because the pull-out
out of afghanistan was handled so poorly
that do you feel like we'll have to go
back again militarily to go
fix the problems created
i sure hope not i sure hope we don't
uh
can you imagine
i mean look
20 years went by
and nothing changed
the taliban was in charge when we went
into afghanistan when we left
afghanistan the taliban was in charge
right
that was with the military that at
various points especially during the
trump years was actually
reasonably well managed
can you imagine if we went in now with
this woke military
that can't win twitter fights
that uh
is all worried about critical race
theory
good point yeah it would take 40 years
and we'd leave and the taliban would be
in charge
yeah okay so i certainly hope we don't
go back in
if we did go back in it would be useless
even if we had a good military because
we have to understand that these are
patient the giants are very patient they
believe they're fighting a 1400 year
struggle
now does this mean that we shouldn't
fight them of course not we should
resist them but we shouldn't think if we
go in and spend five years in
afghanistan we'll fix the problem or ten
years or fifty or a hundred what we need
to do is concentrate on
containing
instead of wilsonian nation building and
trying to make afghanistan like france
instead of doing that we should
concentrate on containing
the jihad threat there and making sure
they can't export their jihad anywhere
else
so the idea that we're bringing afghans
over here it's absolutely insane that's
the opposite of what we should be doing
we should be making sure that afghans
aren't leaving afghanistan
and you say how cruel and heartless you
are because they'll be left to the
ministrations of the taliban well you
know the taliban is actually pretty
popular there
and the people who don't like the
taliban as i have noted before are for
the most part
pro-sharia muslims themselves
so even if we want to have a safe haven
for the people who helped us
there are plenty of place what about
pakistan
then culturally religiously they have a
bond with the people there
pakistan
is right next door could have put them
all there
they'd hardly notice
they would think they were at home
so
in other words what we need to do is
make sure that
911 can't happen again that they can't
export their jihad again but we don't
have to be there militarily to do that
yes thank you
thank you robert you
totally agree we agree
anyone else have a question
robert let me uh as they're thinking let
me ask one more question kind of
a little bit off topic but maybe not
the the war that's been going on between
xi'an and sunni for so long in the
middle east
and with what's going on right now in
syria and iran and iraq
you think there's a chance that they
might just be fighting so much with each
other
that they would
somehow get ahold of a bomb and start
really
serious wars against the country's uh
property
that could trigger a bigger war do you
think that exists or you think there's
restraint enough that that's not a real
risk
no that's a real risk that could happen
but
even the fact that they fight against
each other does not mean that
i mean it's okay look
in a certain sense yes
when they fight against each other then
they're not fighting against us and that
from our standpoint is not a bad thing
and you can say oh that's terrible we
need to go over there and make sure that
the sunnis and shia don't fight each
other
that's condoleezza rice and others you
know have said this kind of thing
that's not our responsibility the the
sunnis and shia were fighting each other
long before there was the united states
and probably will be long after
so
here again
our responsibility is to take care of
ourselves but is it possible that
they are that the their conflict could
spill out
yes and that's what we should be
concentrating on trying to make sure
does not happen
at the same time there's an old arabic
proverb that translates to my brother
against my brother and both of us
against our cousin so even though they
hate each other they'll still work
together against infidels after all
remember
iran is shiite
but they fund hamas which is sunni
because they both hate israel that much
and so the the the jihad against the
west will not end because the sunni
shiite jihad is heating up as it appears
to be
paul you had your hand up
please unmute yourself first
yeah i had uh claire lopez on my show
and she was talking about how iran was
actually one of the financers and had
al-qaeda hiding there
so
i think we're more likely to see the
enemy of my enemy as my friend more
likely with that with shiite and sunni
than anything else
indeed
absolutely
anyone else i don't see any other hands
up
jim hey it's jim hey robert hi jim
great to see you
see you um
i i gotta go actually to another meeting
but before i went uh before i go i want
to ask um
my my view of afghanistan
is that it's actually going to be
much more stable now
not
because the taliban have taken over and
the and
so much you know the other
uh organizations are
not very well able to fight them but
because really people who are going to
be in charge now are communist china
you know your assessment of that because
i think that's what happened you hope so
but you know there might be a few bumps
in the road for them
interesting note yesterday
there was a story out of pakistan
a uh and pakistan is also of course
essentially turning uh i mean china is
turning pakistan into a satellite
and trying to make a a
crescent so to speak of pakistan and
afghanistan and then put pressure on
india
but
the
chinese workers
in a plant in pakistan were attacked
by the pakistani workers because the
pakistani workers thought that something
that they were manufacturing um i've
forgotten what but anyway they thought
it was blasphemous
and so they were enraged and start
beating up the chinese
and i think well this is interesting you
know we can grab some popcorn and see uh
what happens here uh
who's gonna how are the chinese gonna
react to that and uh how is it going to
how is that kind of behavior which is
certain to continue of course
what kind of impact is it going to have
on the uh
on china's plans and that i think is it
bears watching
thanks i gotta go guys thanks good to
see you jim you too robert
thank you
uh jim
coley i look like are you waving or do
you have a question
indeed i'm need to unmute yourself
i'm so used to classrooms where i have
to be quiet
this is terrific thank you very much
robert for for your talk today um one
thing i've thought about is the
situation with israel now with weakened
support from the biden administration
how that will play out i had heard a
thing on actually it was a church where
they had a thing called prophecy update
one thing they had headline they
featured was that israel was parking
f-35s in
azure
azure by song
um
that it's intended
for a possible attack in iran
against nuclear facilities so i don't
know where this is going to
to lead to but
i tell you when it comes between
the jews and
muslims it's a
such a volatile situation
that's interesting azerbaijan of course
is a muslim country but
it uh is at odds with iran
because iran has a significant azeri
minority population
that they want to keep uh
at bay you know they want to keep them
from getting too restless and thinking
hey there's this independent zeri
country right across the border we could
join up with them uh and so
they're very nervous about the azeri's
very hostile to azerbaijan which gives
an opening to israel to deal with
azerbaijan
uh
it may be that there will be more muslim
countries entering the abraham accords
actually because of the shared threat of
iran
and so the biden administration by
appeasing iran may end up actually
aiding israel in the long run we can
hope that would be a good outcome yes we
have about seven more minutes before the
meeting goes uh three questions one is
from on the on the board maria whose
microphone is not working she asked
the problem is that there are members of
the pa i mean palestinian authorities
i'm assuming
in the parliament of israel now was she
referring to one of your earlier
comments robert
yeah they're not just in the parliament
they're in the government
they've been in the knesset for a long
time uh not members of the palestinian
authority as such but members of arab
parties that have made no secret of
their
distaste for israel and desire to
destroy it even though they're in the
israeli parliament
so that you got a now as part of the
ruling coalition of the prime minister
nathalie bennett
you have an arab party that it makes no
secret of wanting sharia
and so uh we'll see how that plays out
all right and carl goldberg you had your
hand up if you could unlike yourself and
after that we'll go to richard o'reilly
okay
you want to unmute yourself or
um christine can you i'm using there
you go
i was just greeting you robert hello
thank you so much
thanks for being here
okay and uh
richard you had your hand up uh no
question here bob
thank you so much
okay we got one gentleman joining us
very late and uh unfortunately he
probably hasn't had a chance to hear
this
wonderful special you want to unmute and
ask a question
sure
i mean
one of the many ways we're getting hit
is robert was just talking about is the
refugees
and
according to the the the
definition of refugees they should be
relocated in a border country settled
there until they can be settled back to
their own country so
by bringing them here and putting them
on a permanent pro-life welfare housing
food education they are doing exactly
what uh robert mentioned they're
bleeding the non-muslims
that along with what the left's going to
our budget
uh i mean we're just we're getting hit
so many ways and i am leading to a
question
but i mean even the defunding the police
our local police is our first contact
with suspicious activity that sometimes
leads to the rest of these people
planning and plotting
our energy and oil policy where we were
the leading energy and oil supply
suppliers
under donald trump that's been taken
away so we're getting hit on all fronts
as you can imagine and i can talk for
another hour about all the other fronts
and as we spoke yesterday robert i asked
you
if uh if there's any type of
recommendation or suggestion you could
say what could we do
but in terms of actions of activities uh
what can we possibly do
to to stop on maybe focus on one of
these fronts and just focus on that but
what can we do as an individual i would
say the main thing that we can do we
must do we all must do right now is work
for election integrity
and for the end of the mail-in balloting
for the end of all this massive cheating
so that we can have fair elections and
if we have fair elections i'm confident
that the american people will vote the
political class out
and bring in people who will start to
tackle these problems instead of making
them worse
so
you have
any
anything you can do to work for that
over the next year
that's what you should focus on
unfortunately a lot of times that gets
tied up in in legal proceedings which
takes years and years and years and i'm
afraid the damage is going to be done
we've got to keep trying it ain't over
till it's over
no we're going to keep fighting thank
you robert
robert thank you so much for a very
stimulating and timely uh presentation
you have stirred the minds of all of us
i'm sure
for those of you who are interested in
knowing more about act for america of
the mischievo chapter
christine can you put up the
slide nine
and we'll take a look at that as we
close our meeting here
and while she's doing that uh i wanna
also mention that if you're interested
in knowing more about act for america if
you're not familiar with the national
organization
you can go to the website which is
www.actforamerica.org
[Music]
and last but not least uh again thank
you all for taking the time to attend
today's meeting and for those who are
not familiar with uh zoom
you have to leave the leading there's a
little leave message or exit in the
lower right hand corner thank you all so
much again
be well god bless
thank you bob
god bless have a good night thank you
good night
good night bob thank you much this is a
great meeting
all right god bless america indeed
goodnight everyone christine thanks so
much for all your good work thanks
christine good job bob okay excellent
carl good seeing you again good seeing
you too bob
thank you thanks bob okay larry i had a
little technical difficulty there but i
don't know why i couldn't pull it up on
my ipad i had to just use my phone which
is really weird yeah because the
technical problem i lost my mic
30 minutes 30 seconds before going into
the presentation so i didn't get the
recording started at times i was messing
around with trying to find out how to
get my microphone working so yeah no
problem
it is recorded but it starts about eight
or nine minutes into the uh you know
into the start of this
everyone should remember to go to
robert's site
ghodwatch.org
to get his books and uh donate to help
him for his cause also
right one last thing he was talking
about the pakistani workers were beating
up the chinese workers for doing what
what did they suspect they were making
i didn't hear that part i must have been
taking notes he didn't he didn't specify
specifically what they were making he
just
he just noted that whatever they were
making was blasphemous to their uh oh
the last one
okay i see i see i got it okay
all right hey all right did anybody
learn a lot gentleman will be in touch
yeah you know just one one thing that i
was gonna try to get robert to talk
about but he didn't have a right place
to put it in he did a paper back in
march of 2020 where he interviewed 80
politically
large figure muslim public officials
asking them would they
um would they rather work under a u.s
constitution or sharia law
what do you think the percentage is that
said they wanted and insisted it be
sharia law
close a little higher
unbelievable unbelievable yeah
yeah we've been we've been tremendously
naive about what's going on that's for
sure yeah and that that just speaks of
the you know how much how much
indoctrination is going on in the in the
mosques
and the organizations that are islamic
related it's it's way way deeper than we
give credit to
yeah
i guess one question i was going to ask
him is there's a lot of people that
don't believe 911 that was actually
carried out by the muslims it was
carried out by somebody else like the
cia
is there any credence to that or we're
just not going to know for a while no
that's not a that's a total bs line that
it's part of you know one of the things
muslims and marxists and communists and
socialists are all very good at that is
create chaos and misdirection and this
misinformation
and there's a big example of it keep
everything up in the air it's part of
the chaotic theme they love to drive
into the country because they think it
gives them a ledge to get their agenda
in because people are so busy looking
left right up and down they're not
paying attention to what's going on in
front of them i mean look at that look
at the evidence as to who
who came in
it was unbelievable
yeah well yeah then you have somebody
like l lynn wood who would normally have
this tremendous credibility saying that
it wasn't done by airplanes i mean
that's bizarre
i'm like what is that about yeah so i
don't know
well anyway
yeah
thanks uh bob i gotta run but i
appreciate it take care thank you be in
touch mary do you have your hand up i
thought yeah because um a lot of people
in the arab world
to this day still believe that the jews
did 9 11.
oh yeah and people have been surveyed in
the middle east the majority believe
that
sad but true
but you know that's again going back to
what the marxists are so good at and the
socialists
those those forces that are working to
tear down our country one of the primary
examples if you look no matter what the
diversion about what flavor it's coming
from
creating chaos
looking the other way
the story that they're putting out isn't
the real story the whole story is they
want to have a revolution and they'll do
anything to stir up the pot to keep
everybody off balance
that's the game
so what you see on the mainstream media
don't believe it
don't believe 99 of what's coming out
there because it's all controlled news
it's funneled through
social networks
through
mainstream television
through people who are in positions of
authority who are respected but they are
working on their own agenda it's coming
at us from so many directions
and it's so easy to follow and believe
it
and it's just be terribly skeptical
about almost everything you hear today
just remember
they've got one big goal in mind and
that's to destroy this country and turn
in socialism ultimately to make it
communism to make it run by a tyrannical
government that doesn't make a
difference whether you're talking about
marxists or communists or socialists or
islamists
all of them defeat america and its
greatness and what it's built on and
that's what we've got to protect
stop using the
software socialists this is a communist
takeover absolutely let's not let them
get by saying progressives or socials
this is communists
so
they're admitting that they're meeting
socialists now so we're five years from
now they're going to admit communists
well let's just start calling the
communists right now yeah we got a lot a
lot of risk going on between taiwan and
china what's going on in the middle east
what's going on between the saudis and
the shia
there's just the the internal battles
within our own country because of all
the the liberal and leftist rules and
the crazy policies that are being
happening in our congress and in white
house in particular
lots of fraud a lot of fronts a lot of
frustration a lot of damage that could
potentially be done to our country
before we elect reasonable people
back in positions of authority in our
government to lead this country but the
damage is going to be deep before we get
to those elections and of course it goes
without saying if we're not fighting for
election integrity so that the vote that
does happen in 2022 and 24 if we don't
really have control of our elections
it's hopeless it's gone we will not have
a chance to recover no matter how many
good people are out there doing the
right thing
and the mainstream media is willingly
compliant
and they're going to be the ones that
they've got the sheep already absolutely
you have to get the message out and we
have to let them know what the truth is
and we have to turn them away from the
mainstream media you're absolutely right
eric absolutely right well they think
i like to simplify things and i can make
if i we could
leave this meeting with some sort of
positive note
um
is that how do we do this how do we
secure our elections
how do we turn this ship around how do
we prevent
next year looking at a democratic
socialist america
because that's their agenda this year
right
and it's really simple guys we've got to
raise our numbers we know that over half
our country voted for trump
right
they are all waiting on the wings
waiting for leaders
to gather them together under their
wings and point them in the right
direction
and the the most simple thing that we
can do is to send real grassroots
thunder and lightning to the hill
into our state capitals
we have all the power
we have all the numbers
and what eric was saying about the media
being complicit
if we're silent
if we're not engaged we are complicit
right and that's the thing that we need
to tell our family our friends our
neighbors we need you to take here's the
action tools takes you two minutes
sacrifice i don't want to hear how busy
you are i've got a two-minute task for
you help us take back america we need to
do that rally cry asking
massive numbers to do the simplest
things and that's how we take it back
that's what every working class american
everyone understands it representative
government cannot represent us if we're
not voicing what it is we're asking them
to do
so
give them a spine give those guys in you
know in those elected seats the spine
and the courage
through our groundswell grassroots
approach that's how we take this country
back is when we the people start acting
like it we have let go
and it's time to take back those reigns
so it's totally possible you already
know the numbers are there remember i
just want to remind you they're there
they're just waiting on the wings let's
gather them up let's unite 1776 strong
1776 unite and let's get this job done
we could do that in the matter of months
if we all were working at that very
thing that simple thing
[Music]
and carl before
uh one way to increase our audience
which i have uh been using oh for a
couple of years now is to leave
relatively short comments no more than
about 200 words on different facebook
groups
because those groups have hundreds and
sometimes thousands of members
who are alerted to
a new comment on their facebook group
there are
thousands of facebook groups around the
country
of republican groups of all kinds
conservative groups of all kinds we can
use that to reach our audience otherwise
we end up speaking to ourselves uh
preaching to the choir but if you want
to reach more people it's go to those
facebook groups as long as facebook
permits us still to do that
good thank you thank you the key is
brevity
yeah the shorter the comment the more
like they are to read it
indeed
indeed well thank you all
wonderful uh sing good friends again
we'll do this again thank you bob
thanks everybody god bless
you bye-bye see you next week bye